es una tecnología que podría ser
superior al cerebro humano y uno de sus
Pioneros dice ahora que una parte del
lamenta haber participado en su creación
Jeffrey Hilton informático de 75 años
dice que dejó su trabajo en Google Para
poder compartir de forma independiente
sus preocupaciones sobre la tecnología
de Inteligencia artificial que incluyen
temores sobre la desinformación y la
pérdida de puestos de trabajos humanos
pero que también va mucho más allá
qué hacemos para mitigar los riesgos a
largo plazo de que cosas más
inteligentes que nosotros tomen el
control cosas como el chipity Four
eclipsan a una persona en la cantidad de
conocimiento generales que posee y la
eclipsan con creces en términos de
razonamiento no es tan bueno pero ya
hace razonamiento simples y dado el
ritmo del Progreso Esperamos que las
cosas mejoren bastante rápido así que
tenemos que preocuparnos por eso
es solo la última advertencia de que las
empresas tecnológicas podrían estar
creando un monstruo que no controlar en
marzo después de qué opinais lanzar el
último modelo su chatbot más de mil
personas del sector tecnológico entre
ellas el multimillonario elon musk y el
cofundador de Apple Steve wosniak
firmaron una carta pidiendo una
moratoria en el desarrollo de la
Inteligencia artificial Hilton también
pidió a los desarrolladores que hicieran
una pausa el jefe científico de Google
respondió a sus entrevistas en un
comunicado seguimos comprometidos con un
enfoque responsable de la Inteligencia
artificial aprendemos continuamente para
comprender los riesgos emergentes al
tiempo que innovamos con audacia el
propio Hilton afirmó que Google ha
actuado hasta ahora como un
administradora adecuado de la tecnología
pero que está sufriendo una presión cada
vez mayor por parte de la competencia
advierte que los gigantes tecnológicos
están atrapados en una carrera que
requerirá una regulación mundial para
frenarla